خسر مدينه باخمت في اوكرانيا لكنه حصل على
تعويض في اليابان
في هيروشيما على هامش قمه مجموعه السبع
التقى الرئيس الاوكراني نظيره الامريكي جو
بايدن تمخض اللقاء بتعهد بايدن بتقديم
مساعدات لاوكرانيا قيمتها
375 مليون دولار
المساعدات العسكريه الجديده لكييف تشمل
انظمه صواريخ مدفعيه عاليه الحركه هاي
مارس قذائف مدفعيه من عيار 155 مليمترات
صواريخ تاو مضاده للدبابات
صواريخ متنقله من طراز سي يو اس موجهه
بالليزر انظمه مدرعه لبناء الجسور
شاحنات ومقطورات لنقل المعدات الثقيله
معدات دعم لوجيسي انظمه تصوير حراريه
سيارات اسعاف مصفحه قطع غيار ومعدات
ميدانيه اخرى
علاوه على تدريب الجيش الاوكراني بحسب
البيت الابيض
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات